[Musique]
bonsoir à tous et bienvenue sur tv 78
pour un nouveau numéro du 7 8 sociétés
votre rendez vous hebdomadaire pour
débattre discuter et réfléchir sur les
grands enjeux qui font l'actualité et
qui rythme notre vie alors rués sur les
oeufs la farine ou encore les pattes on
a tous en tête ces images découvertes en
mars 2020 al'annonce du premier confie
nommés pour certains français
ça a été l'occasion de se lancer dans le
doubs 8 sur 16 mais est-ce que les deux
confinement successifs ou booster cette
mode de créer de nombreuses choses
soi-même on en parle avec nos deux
invités du soir elena glilot artiste
plasticienne et créatrice de zai chic un
site de tutoriels artistique et de
loisirs bonsoir montréal stéphanie
hogday vous êtes membre et fondateur de
l'association vers hybride à la verrière
non soir alors selon un sondage toluna
pour le site de fourniture avec cette
année 43% des français ont prévu
d'offrir un cadeau fait main pour noël
et l'agglo vous même en tant que
créatrice en tant qu artiste
plasticienne est ce que vous êtes lancé
aux cédants dans ses cadeaux de noël
fait maison
alors pour moi c'est j'avoue que noël
c'est préparer nos unités à la fois le
gros stress de l'année et c'est vraiment
un projet tracker
je ne conçois plus aujourd'hui de fêter
noël sans avoir fabriqué le principal
canaux pour maisons souvent je fais des
grosses choses donc maison un tableau
comme quelque chose qui me tient à coeur
d'apprendre à partager
voilà mais depuis plusieurs semaines ont
entaché la nuit je leur avais aucune
idée jolie surprise pour moi mais je
fais ça depuis bellamy stefaniuk des
mairies green c'est aussi de réduire les
déchets donc on sait à noël il ya
beaucoup d'emballage de cadeaux à ce que
vous même vous êtes partie sur du
fait-main cette année pour vos projets
pour la première année romain j'avais un
petit peu initiés mais cette année le
principal de mes cadeaux c'est aussi du
fait maison des produits cosmétiques sa
maison dans des boîtes de fabriquer en
origami donc fait maison tous pareils
tous a englobé dans des bureaux chez qui
cette année j'ai passé aussi quel que
soit le longue soirée à fabriquer des
faux rochers qui pour avoir assez de
papier fait maison en fait je veux juste
que justement pour les emballages very
green a aussi proposé des ateliers
autour de noël avec la commanderie de
saint quentin en yvelines
est-ce que vous avez vu un engouement
pour vos ateliers
alors d'après les templiers
enfin d'après le personnel templiers
notre notre atelier à estaires des
premiers rempli en fait avec les
attentes
il ya eu vraiment une grosse demande des
gens ont envie d'apprendre en fait à
faire à faire eux-mêmes sur des choses
simples mais ils ont envie et et après
les retours qu'on a eues il certains je
sais sont en train de faire pour noël
certains produits qu'on a fabriqué
ensemble alors en juin le ministère de
la culture a publié une étude des
pratiques culturelles en temps de
confinement la pratique amateur du
dessin de la peinture de la sculpture et
de la gravure est passé de 14% 14% sur
toute l'année 2010 8 à 20% pour une
période seulement de cette semaine en
2020 elena guilaume comment vous
expliquez que certains français se
soient tournés vers les activités
manuelles
alors que la pratique de la lecture elle
a plutôt dégringolé à je pense que c'est
une vraie thérapie où je pense que dans
l'eure je pense que là d'un coup on
ferme et bientôt ça sera question tourne
à l'envers en cours et et vous allez
c'était moi je me prends collabore
souvent avec ce titre et je sais que
suivi ses lives s'enrôler le confinement
est selon cette étude du ministère de la
culture les plus concernés sont les des
jeunes les 15 24 ans est ce que vous
l'avez ressenti non des demandes de
peut-être sur votre site sur votre
instagram technique entre 30 et 50
arrêts et encore des années 90 que du
coup cette attente et devant stéphanie
godet vous aussi avez green est ce que
vous avez vu plus tôt les jeunes se
lancer dans cette démarche du faire soi
même pouces et une autre génération qui
s'est laissé tenter nous on est aussi
plus proche de 35,3 des comptes entre
pareil 30 45 50 ans mais on a quand même
eu l'année dernière on a des jaunards le
confinement a tout arrêté hélas mais en
janvier on a des jeunes de vives lui qui
faisait leur mémoire que la réduction
des déchets et de goût qui nous avait
rejoints et que nous suivaient d'autres
enfin qu'ils me doivent aider à se
développer et qui devait faire des
actions avec nous à lui vécu mais ont
finalement décidé autrement
alors nous avons aussi voulu voir
reprenne nos téléspectateurs si eux
aussi avaient succombé au deutsch
yourself c'est le sondage de la semaine
et ils ont répondu non à 55%
est-ce que vous dans vos deux domaines
le côté plutôt que loisirs créatifs le
côté plutôt écologique vous avez vu vous
un intérêt grandissant et les nagui
longue peut-être en premier et écoutez
moi clairement je suis vu le nombre de
personnes qui suivaient les live
et sur mon compte et sur le compte doit
s'envoler et j'ai vu aussi les échanges
s'intensifier en fait avec avec des fans
pour mon compte
elena that chick avec une une demande de
comment tu fais ça tu me demandes de
partage de l'empreinte automatique sur
l'aspect esthétique des choses mais un
grand stéphane et au godet est ce que
vous c'était peut-être des demandes de
conseils
est ce qu'il ya eu des demandes de tutos
lié sans doute à des consciences
écologiques que ce virus aussi a pu
réveiller nous pond un confinement
c'était plutôt calme sur nos réseaux
sociaux je pense que tout le monde était
un peu et personnellement à l'essai au
deuxième confinement on avait un peu
plus de réactions
le premier est vraiment calme deuxième
on n'avait plus de réaction et du coût
des demandes sont apparus mais plutôt
personnellement on a une notion est bon
d une association dont on n'a pas non
plus énormément de temps et c'était des
conseils individuels mais quelques les
demandes portées sur quoi on sait que
maintenant qu'on a tendance à se lancer
dans la fabrication de produits ménagers
notamment personnel ce qu'il y ait aussi
une méfiance sur certains produits nous
laisser en fait c'est au tour des
produits que nous fabriquons nous mêmes
en atelier en propose quelques produits
on propose autour de l'évier le produit
la vaisselle et comment faire la
vaisselle 160 produits
on va dire acheter dans le commerce on
propose aussi des galets pour nettoyer
les wc on propose de remplacer les
éponges par des townships donc là les
gens en fait nous ont contacté des gens
qui ont déjà participé en fait à nos
ateliers et qui demandait des conseils
ou des piqûres de rappel parce qu'ils
oublient comme en intérieur à propose
plusieurs recettes parfois ils oublient
certaines choses mais les deux nouvelles
personnes
mais en attendant les coups de fer avec
nous beaucoup d'attentes de faire en
direct en fait
et justement est-ce que vous ça vous à
bhl obligé si on peut dire à trouver de
nouvelles idées à l'esa fouillé faire
vous même des recherches des petites
recettes avant de les proposer à vos
adhérents nous ont fait énormément de
recherches avant alors qu'il ya des
choses qu'on utilise nous mêmes mais par
exemple là pour noël donc on a eu une
commande de la commanderie des templiers
pour fabriquer une petite boîte avec eux
dans des cosmétiques pour les bas et on
a déjà mené ici des petites choses mais
on a donc fait des recherches pour
fabriquer les petites bombes de bain
fait soi même et puis un baume pour les
lèvres
enfin pour le corps en fait un pardon un
gommage pour le corps or une bonne pour
le et une crème pour le corps tout ça
dans une petite boîte mais au 10è en
origami vous avez vous tous vous avez
pas ça nous avons des quelques heures de
préparation et l'aîné guillaume est ce
que vous vous êtes attachés ou est ce
qu'on vous a demandé de créer notamment
des activités destinées aux enfants ou à
faire en famille parce qu'à partir du
mois de mars tout le monde était
enfermée en famille à la maison mon dieu
nous amener quelque chose quand j'écris
la ferme et donc avec les la grande
nouveauté pour moi c'est que j'avais les
enfants à ce que j'avais à l'époque
j'avais beaucoup de projets mais plein
de et du coup il fait extra juste la
classe affaires et maxi fille de trois
ans et demi à l'époque qui était un peu
livrée à elle même dans la maison et
alors j'ai éprouvé le besoin je sais pas
ce qu'on voit le tutoriel est sur le fil
wind mobile comment c'est la première
chose que j'ai fait j'ai repensé à des
choses
il m'avait beaucoup amusé enfant je
voulais vérifier si elles étaient
inconscients des dangers domestiques
puisqu'elle était amené à se balader
dans la maison que moi je pouvais être
un fonds school par exemple je ne fais
pas les la surveiller dans une pièce je
suis dit mais est ce qu'elle sait il
faut pas couché les produits ménagers
les
fils électriques etc donc j'ai créé ce
petit jeu et je dis j'ai fini par le
public je me suis dit que ça pouvait
intéresser d'autres parents c'est
vraiment destiné aux enfants de voilà de
l'âge de la maternelle à peu près donc
représente toutes les cases donc c'est
très simple tu découpes et un quart
temps vous pouvez le faire vous même
vous représentez schématiquement des
principales caisses de la maison dior
s'est il y avait avec des avec des
choses un imprimé et vous pourrez placer
tous les dangers domestiques dans les
pièces donc ne pas tomber dans
l'escalier la baignoire d'eau voilà des
petites choses comme ça que j'avais
jamais vu tous mes dessins à disposition
des gens pour qu'ils puissent les les
découper les placer dans les pièces et
faire comme un jeu de société en fait
dire à l'enfant est bien dans cette
pièce il ya trois dangereux et puis un
objet qui lui patron joseph aussi venir
qu'est-ce qui est pas dangereux et et je
crois que j'ai dû partager et publier et
moi énormément rasséréné de voir que ma
cheville
sarr est à peu près de quoi les chalets
pas sa prochaine pièce que vous aussi
vous avez adapté par rapport aux
programmes scolaires on sait que
certains professeurs ont rivalisé
d'imagination sur les réseaux sociaux
pour continuer à enseigner à leurs
élèves mais vous est ce qu'on vous a
demandé des activités liées à certains
exercices qu'on peut faire à l'école
donc ça j'ai pas j'ai pas eu des
échanges particulier avec les
instituteurs je sais que dans les
confinements le vraiment accusés ont mis
du temps à se mettre en route et puis
après j'avais une fille en cm2 donc avec
un an j'ai dansé au collège que c'était
très intense en termes de volumes et de
contenu mais on était vraiment de
loisirs créatifs l'éguille pour les
outils la maternelle voilà les
maîtresses pour hyper au point sur ces
sujets là nous alimenter facilement
après moi je me disais forcément
accompli peau etc
j'ai pas les échanges par en particulier
stéphanie godet vous allez donner
quelques pistes tout à l'heure avec ce
que vous avez pu créer avec la
commanderie mais est ce qu'on peut faire
tout soi-même quand on pense produits
ménagers produits de beauté est ce que
finalement tout ce qu'on utilise au
quotidien on peut le faire nous mêmes
alors tout le maquillage ça reste
compliqué certains apprennent à se
rapprocher de professionnels il ya des
géniales ya des choses qu'on peut par
contre un produit ménager jeunes ont
tout se fait soi même avec quelques
produits l'acide citrique les vitres des
bus ou des cristaux de soude et de
vinaigre blanc
avec ces quatre éléments vous faites
tous les produits ménagers dont vous
avez besoin pour les cosmétiques bon
c'est un petit peu plus mais pour les
basilic les crèmes corps le baume à
lèvres le shampoing ça le shampoing
c'est un incontournable
le dentifrice voilà c'est vraiment le
maquillage ça on se lance pas de danse
et c'est assez compliqué c'est assez
complexe
on va conclure cette émission sur ces
mots pour ce qui est de certaines
recettes du recel fiona certaine que
l'association a proposé sur notre
antenne pour ce qui est de vos activités
elena ghislain on peut les retrouver
bien sûr sur votre site et votre page
instagram pour very green la page
facebook record il ya beaucoup
d'activités pardon sur votre page
facebook
le cette société c'est terminé pour
cette année 2020 vous pouvez revoir
notre émission en replay sur notre site
internet et notre application mobile
prenez soin de vous
[Musique]